bonsoir et bienvenue à vous sur les
chaînes parlementaires et politiques
public sénat et lcp haine c'est un
plaisir de vivre cette soirée politique
en votre compagnie c'était le temps fort
de cette campagne d'entre deux tours un
duel qui était très attendu un choc
frontal entre les deux finalistes
emmanuel macron et marais d'opale
alors cette confrontation at elle permis
une clarification qui s'est imposée
vraiment au final ce débat aura t elle
un impact sur la france du ni-ni et
surtout apporte-t-il des réponses
concrètes aux doutes aux interrogations
des français at il été aussi à la
hauteur des enjeux de notre pays en ce
moment c'est une question très
importante
on va en débat durant une heure ce soir
à mes côtés c'est ludovic faux
journalistes politiques lcpan bonsoir
les deux vies et nos premiers invités ce
soir le politologue olivier rouquan
bonsoir judith waintraub journaliste
politique au figaro bonsoir patrick apel
muller directeur de la rédaction de
l'humanité bonsoir à vous notre
chroniqueur j'en ai compris sa compagne
bonsoir mon sur saône une première
question ludovic fo s'était fait que je
posais à l'instant qui me paraît quand
même essentiel est majeur en ce moment
même est ce que ce débat est à la
hauteur des enjeux que l'on vit en tout
cas pas sûr que les français es tu ce
soir les réponses à toutes les questions
qu'ils pouvaient se poser sur les enjeux
qui attendent la france et sur le
programme des deux candidats parce qu'on
était ce soir finalement dans un débat
un peu hors normes
finalement comme toute cette campagne
présidentielle on était assez loin des
débats en général assez polis et émaillé
de quelques passes d'armé entre les
candidats comme on a pu le voir lors dès
lors des dernières élections
là on était quasiment dans un combat de
catch est un dû au vu du début à la fin
avec des attaques frontales souvent au
détriment du fond de la clarté est
effectivement au niveau parfois du débat
on n'a pas toujours eu l'impression
d'avoir deux candidats à l'élection
présidentielle et c'est est notamment dû
à la stratégie de marine le pen qui dès
le début a essayé de prendre à la gorge
emmanuel macron essayé de le pousser
dans ses retranchements l'obligé à
perdre son calme
et face à cette stratégie emmanuel
macron a voulu montrer qu'il était
capable d'être combative de répondre du
tac au tac alors il a essayé de faire de
la pédagogie
mais il est parfois peut-être tomber
dans le piège que lui tendait marine le
pen
on a souvent qualifié jeudi de 23 à
raison cette campagne dit
edit comment vous vous qualifiez ce soir
ce duel inédit
c'était la première fois qu'une
candidats représentant du front national
avait avait donc un débat d'entre deux
tours puisqu'on sait que jacques chirac
l'avait refusée avec jean marie le pen
donc forcément inédit moi je trouve que
pour répondre à la question essentielle
que vous avez posé sur est ce que ce
débat éclairé les français je crois que
la réponse est malheureusement non même
si je serai moins sévère que ludovic sur
le niveau des débats
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des insultes des
dons d'oiseaux il ya eu une attitude
extrêmement arrogant
d'ailleurs le mot est revenue plusieurs
fois professoral presque d'emmanuel
matheron notamment au début sur
l'économie où on voyait de marine le pen
assez accroché à ses fiches elle les a
beaucoup regardé et 8 profitant de sa
maîtrise du fait d'être très à l'aise
dans ce registre qu'à un peu trop
c'était pas la peine ça se voyait ça se
voyait qu'il était davantage son domaine
à lui mais juste pour revenir donc sur
le fait est ce que ça a éclairé ou pages
principe exemple le financement des deux
programmes
marine le pen a un programme extrêmement
social on avait l'impression que son
coeur de cible ce soir c'était les
électeurs qui ont voté pour jean luc
mélenchon à la fois parce qu'il parlait
beaucoup de la soumission
le mot est revenu comme un gimmick dans
son discours de liberté de souveraineté
et puisqu'elle faisait beaucoup de
promesses et de promesses sociales
or la seule mesure qu'elle est cité
d'éventuels financements c'est la taxe
sur l'importation
ce qui ne veut strictement rien dire
parce que prenons par exemple les
ordinateurs qu'on fabrique très très peu
en france sur ces 95% qui sont apportées
qui va la payer la taxe sur les
ordinateurs bat le français qui en fait
lui qui va en finale à et inversement
emmanuel macron lui n'a pas dit un mot
de la façon dont il comptait faire c'est
soixante milliards d'économie qui
mettaient en regard des six aides aux
entreprises
on va parler des écueils je reste quand
même encore toujours sur l'aspect
général pour compléter ce tour de table
jean louis gombeaud l'une des boussoles
dont nous avons souvent parlé ici même
c'est ce qu'on a appelé la
présidentialité alors qu'est ce que ça
veut dire c'est quand même beaucoup la
crédibilité en regardant ce match ce
catch pour reprendre ce que vous avez
dit au début qu'il faut ce soir
gagner français ils ont devant eux le
futur chef d'état chef des armées chef
aussi entre guillemets en tous les cas
celui qui va guider leurs leur destin
pendant cinq ans par rapport à ces
enjeux là qu'est ce qu'ils ont vu ce
soir alors la crédibilité si la
crédibilité dans la combativité
est ce que ça peut être ça aussi les
deux se sont montrés particulièrement
combatif si la crédibilité et dans la
connaissance des dossiers je dirais
quand même que macron semble quand même
plus à l'aise sur des dossiers complexes
notamment les questions économiques ou
une amie quand même pas mal à mal sa
partenaire si je puis dire sa
concurrente
c'est vrai que l'un et l'autre par
exemple ceux ceux dont on vient de
parler judith on pourrait te faire la
même remarque pour madame le pen que
pour monsieur mâcon car monsieur macron
ne nous a pas dit il a parlé de 60
milliards d'économies mais elles ne sont
pas des lignes étaient donc non je veux
dire les deux jours ce terrain là était
plutôt était plutôt fragile cela dit
qu'est ce qu'on a dit avant l'élection
par deux entre les deux tours on a dit
que cette discussion cette confrontation
montrer véritablement les deux
oppositions frontales qui existent en
france les a vus ou pas vu ou l'aesa
évidemment vu je pense que la forme a
été décevante sur le plan sur le plan
l'intérêt parce que vraiment il
s'interrompt paix tout le temps et
c'était bon si vous vouliez du spectacle
vous avez vu sur le fond ça pas été si
décevant que cela parce qu'en fait
toutes les grandes questions sont venus
et ont été plus ou moins
superficiellement ou plus ou moins
fondamentale abordé par les deux on a
bien vu que en fait d'un côté on avait
la protection europe protection nation
plutôt et de l'autre côté réformes
libérales europe
on a vu sur le sens et j'ai ma soeur
l'orangé pour c'est un tour de table
olivier rouquan j'ajouterai la
présidentialité crédibilité je jetterai
presque dignité dans ces moments au
déficit
oui il est revenu mais ce qu on peut
l'attribuer nous mêmes ici en puisqu'on
commente le débat à ce débat ce serait
prétentieux on va pas tomber dans le
péché la regarde
donc la dignité les 100 salles de côté
par contre il est vrai que c'est le
débat le duel a finalement de second
tour à l'heure des tweets une série d'
attaques parfois très personnelles
donc on est bien là dans un spectacle
renouvelé vous parliez de spectacle mais
renouvelée à un rythme très rapide et
qui donc est corrosif de l'explicatif de
l'est du temps l'explication donc là on
a eu un débat où les flashs se heurter
les uns les autres et même si le fonds a
été abordé le fond est abordé sous la
forme de j'allais dire express donc je
ne suis pas sûr que le téléspectateur
puisse vraiment s'y retrouver
vous avez par exemple à peu près la
moitié des ânes des électeurs qui est
vautré mulhouse blanc qui explique
aujourd'hui qu'ils étaient indécis avant
ce débat
bon ben c'est un exemple je ne suis pas
sûr que ça les aide beaucoup à faire un
choix et on peut faire également la même
barre pour les éventuels
abstentionnistes donc en ligne de mire
et dia ceci c'était aussi le pari pour
ces deux candidats mobilisés et cette
succession de flash qui partaient dans
tous les sens et parfois il ya quand
même eu un long moment
où on est et la cde c'était un peu
répétitif les attaques et contre
attaques c'était un peu circulaire ça
tournait en boucle un peu comme les
réseaux sociaux donc c'est assez
intéressant de voir
l'analogie et ou alors vous avez parlé
de la france d1 d'essayer des
abstentionnistes et patrick apel-muller
on s'intéresse à la france qui gronde
celles qui souffrent 7 qui s'inquiète
pour ses enfants celle qui vit là des
indices réalisation celle qui se sent
elle veut dire le mot méprisé aussi
qu'est ce qu'elle peut penser ce soir
cette france-là qui étend de l de
réponses concrètes mais moi je crois pas
qu'il y ait de france ou 2e partie
frontale de la france qui sont posées
ici qui résumera ce que sont les débats
en france
d'abord je pense que beaucoup de
spectateurs sont pas retrouvés dans ce
débat et notamment dans la bataille de
chiffonniers dans marine le pen a pris
l'initiative et qui a conduit ce débat a
fonctionné par formule type j'allais
dire éléments de langage préparé à
l'avancé marine le pen a commencé son
émission en essayant de s'adresser
précisément à ceux qui sont en colère en
reprenant quelquefois des mots des
programmes du parti communiste jean luc
mélenchon pour essayer de faire révolté
et puis ensuite et les retombées
d'ailleurs dans un discours qui
s'adressait directement l'électorat le
plus à droite avec l'immigration la
sécurité avec l'identité etc etc
c'était très attendu tandis que manuel
emmanuel macron à manifester grande
arrogance technocratique une facilité
technocratiquement temps d'exposer de
ses positions mais sur un fond d'écran
non je te revois pas dos à dos parce que
je pense que ce que représente marine le
pen et bp plus dangereux encore que ce
que représente emmanuel macron mais je
ne suis pas sûr que pour quelqu'un qui
rêve de transformation progrès social
d'égalité de justice etc
il est plus trouvé matière à se nourrir
dans le discours de manuel mais on va
continuer à en parler parce que la
première fois quand même que deux
candidats qui ne sont pas issus des
structures politiques traditionnels
s'affronter c'était inédit streit angle
là on va d'abord s'arrêter sur une
punchline comme on les appelle
maintenant c'est un affrontement vous
allez entendre propos contre propos la
question qui est posée aujourd'hui à nos
concitoyens c'est de savoir s'ils
veulent l'esprit de défaites que vous
portez ce que ce que vous portez c'est
l'esprit des fêtes c'est d'expliquer à
nos concitoyens c'est trop dur la
mondialisation pour nous c'est trop dur
l'europe donc on va se replier on va
fermer les frontières on va sortir de
l'euro sortir de l'europe parce que les
autres y arrive mais pas nous c'est
l'esprit des fêtes dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme
parce que cette lutte tous les pays
développés l'ont toutes les démocraties
ont à la conduire mais vous vous dites
non on va encore là aussi sortir
remettent les frontières comme avant
comme 6 à régler le problème mais nous y
reviendrons
face à cet esprit de défaite moi je
porte l'esprit de conquête français
voilà c'est l'un des moments
d'affrontements le dvi faut qu est-ce
que vous en font penser à ce que ce
genre de punch line comme on dit il
montre vraiment qu'il ya c'est ce que
veut dire emmanuel macron deux presque
philosophique politique qui s'affrontent
oui incontestablement ça on a bien
compris qu'il y avait effectivement de
vision de la société de la france et du
monde qui s'affrontaient on n'a pas eu
toutes toutes les réponses très très
concrètes sur les propositions elles
mêmes et on a bien compris et c'est à
sao 6r ce genre de débat qui avait deux
visions deux incarnations qui était
proposé aux français de la france qui
étaient de très très différente de ce
point de vue là après sur la forme les
punchlines sais c'est un peu devenu
le débat au goût du jour c'est à dire
que marine le pen les a multiplié dès le
début du débat en accusant emmanuel
macron d'être le candidat de la france
qui se soumet elle expliquait qu'elle
était elle la candidate du pouvoir
d'achat alors que lui serait le candidat
du pouvoir d'acheter donc c'est un peu
peut-être qu'on peut reprocher
d'ailleurs à emmanuel macron c'est
peut-être d'être venu un peu sur ceux
sur ce terrain de marine le pen qui
voulait vraiment faire de ce débat une
confrontation et qui a cherché en fait à
m emmanuel macron en difficulté sur sa
personnalité
bell a dit d'ailleurs quand elle trouvé
qu'il n'était peut-être pas suffisamment
agacé à son goût c'est elle qui anime et
monsieur macron vous êtes énervé et ses
élus et parfois est un peu entrer dans
ce jeu là alors que sa stratégie de
départ à lui et il a essayé d'y revenir
quand même au fur et à mesure du débat
était plutôt de démonter le programme le
projet de marine le pen sur le fond
c'est ce qu'il a essayé de faire entre
ces échanges effectivement parfois
parfois assez assez rude en essayant de
faire de la pédagogie
alors qui parfois du coup pouvait
sembler un petit peu laborieuse dans un
débat qui était par ailleurs très très
animée et donc on était à la fois dans
des temps forts et dans des temps
parfois un peu plus long qui était
peut-être plus près cette session
déroutante un de ces temps là on va
revenir sur le choc des projets c'est ça
ce qui nous intéresse aussi mais restons
sur les personnalités jeudi de 20
trophées sont deux candidats nouveau au
fond emmanuel macron le connaissais pas
depuis quelques temps et puis marine le
pen avait présenté une autre image
d'elle même oui et d'ailleurs elle a pas
mal réussi parce que
tous les tous les tous les
téléspectateurs ont déjà vu marine le
pen s'énerver pour la bonne et simple
raison que chaque fois qu'elle est en
interview elle est angélique rappelle
qu'à journalistes essayent de la
débusquer donc les pulls et les
interlocuteurs hostile elle connaît le
elle ne fréquente que ça peut-être sur
sa chaîne youtube je sais pas mais en
tout cas
en règle générale avec habituel elle
elle ne s'est pas énervé elle est pas
sorti ses gonds et face à elle emmanuel
macron qui avait joué une carte très
très importante pour lui qui a bien
fonctionné au premier temps c'était
rappelez-vous le candidat de l'optimisme
avec ce que savait de plaisant
d'agréables notamment par rapport à
françois fillon qui décrivait une france
sur le déclin confrontés à des
difficultés terribles qui disait c'est
sa dernière chance après ça y est on
tombe dans le fond de la ville bah en
fait ce qu'il a donné à voir avec cette
idée d'esprit de conquête c'est une
autre version de l'optimisme qui a
constitué à mon avis une de ses forces
au premier tour alors ça présente
quelques inconvénients
l'un d'entre eux qui s'est vu aussi ce
soir je trouve c'est un certain
angélisme
par exemple dans sa façon d'aborder la
question du terrorisme et du
communautarisme
il a fait un développement assez long
sur les déséquilibres et sur la
responsabilité du système éducatif
français du terreau français il l'a
confirmé ce qu'il avait dit devant les
gracques pas à pas un seul instant il
n'a dit que l'islamisme avait un
quelconque rapport avec l'islam
non je trouve que sur la question du
terrorisme il a bien tenu puisque les
commentaires avant étaient deux
premières fayyad en premier et je pense
que là il a fermé servier ancien lité
sur un enjeu sur le circuit fera
défavorable sur une phrase c'était assez
bien vu de sa part c'est à dire que
c'est là où il a parlé également de la
fonction de chef d'état et chef des
armées sur une phrase qu avec ces termes
il s'est placé en situation de présider
ce que n'a pas fait une seule fois
marine le pen elle n'a pas dit - chefs
d'état ou moins chef des armées ce qui
est assez curieux d'ailleurs et sur la
question il fait le choisit de le faire
non pas sur l'économique et son terrain
de force mais sur la question des
terrines donc je crois que c'est assez 1
aux tab
parce que bon c'est conforme un gars en
présidentialité qu'il recherche sur ce
sur ce terrain et sur le fond il a
montré la fermeté par exemple il a bien
expliqué la mécanique qui est
institutionnel qui voulait mettre en
place qui d'ailleurs pourrait faire
sourciller les plus attentifs à l'état
droit c'est-à-dire présidentialiser la
lutte contre le terrorisme et gérer ceci
directement à l'elysée
institutionnellement ce qui serait un
changement institutionnel sur
l'islamisme
elle lui sort des phrases qui ont
effectivement été prononcées qui sont
effectivement incompatible avec la
république intolérable qu'est ce que ça
lui coûtait de dire oui c'est
intolérable
donc vous n'êtes pas d'accord déjà sur
cet aspect là la lutte contre le
terrorisme
on va aller dans quelques instants sur
le terrain économique et social quand
même tout la priorité des français
ludovic faut les réseaux sociaux ne
sentent un peu l'écumé des vagues faire
attention mais ce qui ressort ce soir
pour beaucoup en tout cas qui ont suivi
c'est un débat plutôt décevant pour le
téléspectateur
mais sur le froid est-ce que vraiment
ils auraient pu contenu de l'agressivité
qu'il y avait contenu des échanges
vraiment très fréquent de la dynamique
doit s qu'ils auraient pu davantage
aller sur le fond ces deux candidats
disons qu'ils ne sont pas autant
empêcher esquisse qui pose est peut-être
une difficulté un c'est finalement le
le rapport de force de cet entre deux
tours c'est à dire qu'on a deux
candidats même si l'écart s'est un peu
resserré dans les sondages ces derniers
jours on a quand même deux candidats qui
sont séparés par environ 10 points
grosso modo c'est 60 40 dans les
intentions de vote ce qui fait qu'on
avait deux candidats qui étaient dans
des situations finalement très très
différentes on avait marine le pen qui
était obligé de tenter le tout pour le
tout et qui n'avait pas grand chose à
perdre donc elle a essayé un peu de
renverser la table en ce montant
effectivement très très très offensive
et on avait de l'autre côté emmanuel
macron qui lui avait pour principal
objectif à la fois de ne pas faire de
fautes ce qui aurait pu lui coûter cher
et puis en même temps d'essayer de
convaincre au maximum donc il n'était
pas tout à fait dans la même stratégie
et de ce point de vue là on a presque
l'impression qu alors qu emmanuel macron
était effectivement en quête de
présidentialité c'est à dire ne rien
lâcher sur la forme et par être
pédagogue sur le fond il avait face à
lui finalement marine le pen qui était
déjà presque dans dans le rôle de celle
qui tente de présenter la position
d'opposante numéro 1 au lendemain de
l'élection dont de ce point de vue là on
a vu dans les législatives on avait deux
candidats qui n'avaient pas tout à fait
la même stratégie et qui déjà joué un
petit peu il reste un pôle après
élection présidentielle c'est peut-être
ce qui explique emmanuel lacroix a
laissé passer certaines énormité je
pense notamment à marine le pen
affirmant que la grande bretagne ne
s'est jamais aussi bien portée que de le
brun existe c'est juste absolument
n'importe quoi puisque je vous rappelle
que la grande bretagne via ton clan
chebah on va laisser sus on va aller sur
le terrain économique et social qui a
été très important encore un mot et là
je vais faire un tour de table rapide
sur le rassemblement
patrick apel muller parce qu'au
lendemain du 7 mai et mais emmanuel
macron l'a d'ailleurs rappelé l'un des
principaux défis ça va être celui de
rassembler c'est pas un mot creux 20
rassembler cette france là où on voit
beaucoup d'électeurs déçus désabusé par
des leurs candidats qui ont été défaits
c'est pas une mince affaire
est-ce qu'il a été rassembleur je ne
crois pas qu'il ait beaucoup progressé
de ce point de vue je pense qu'il n'a
pas rassemblé
gauche et qu'il n'a pas tellement plus
rassemblée à droite
je pense en revanche qu'il a réussi à ne
pas faire de faute majeure qu'il aurait
complètement encombré pour la suite mais
je crois que les 60% bastille qui
constitue son électorat que ce qui en
fin d'année si nom de votre par défaut
de votre part utilité et non par
conviction n'auront pas été beaucoup
plus convaincus par par cette émission
et au lendemain du 7 mai ce problème va
être entier il sera entier au moment des
élections législatives il sera entre
entier dans la période sociale parce
qu'il annonce des réformes extrêmement
rude
il évoque notamment sur le droit du
travail je ne pense pas qu'il aura qu'il
aura convaincu quant à marine le pen je
ne crois pas qu'elle élargisse justement
là dans lé travail on écoute les propos
les changes sur ce sujet important
essayer de faire oublier que vous allez
participer à un gouvernement qui a mis
en oeuvre la loi elle comme rick a été
une loi encore une fois de précarisation
du travail qui n'a pas créé un emploi
qu'à créer un chômage qui est encore
plus important depuis que vous êtes
partis du gouvernement que quand vous y
est entré mais ça je vois que vous
refusé d'en assumer la responsabilité
des dommages implicite non mais je note
que vous refusez encore une fois cette
responsabilité qui est extraordinaire
c'est qu'on ne nous répondait en fait
jamais aux questions vous parlez
toujours du passé et des autres mais
c'est très bien les français
comprendront vous n'avez rien à proposer
c'est formidable je vous écoute vous
parlez du coup vous écoutiez loin de
tout de vous entendre il ya jeudi j'ai
répondu terrain économique et social le
chômage mais aussi la retraite la
protection sociale et la loi travail
jean le combo votre verdict est ce
qu'ils ont été au clair sur ces pays il
ya un fait actuel c'est que ce que dit
madame le pen n'est pas exact en fait
monsieur mac ont pensé pouvoir faire la
loi mâcon 2 et comme lyon le lui a
retiré il est parti c'est à dire que
monsieur hollande à penser que la loi
mâcon 2 tels que la verrez l'aurait vu
monsieur mâcon allé beaucoup trop loin
par rapport au projet elle conneries
docu-réalité sur cette question là on ne
peut pas lui imputer une responsabilité
quelconque puisqu'il est parti sur ce
dossier là qu'il n'a pas pu traiter
contrairement à juste les candidats ni
emmanuel macron le candidat donc dans
marche nous verrons avec ses soutiens le
candidat lui-même ce qu'il pense que le
bilan qu'il fait de s'asseoir et récents
sur ce terrain économique et social
est ce qu'on peut dire quand même sur ce
terrain là jeudi devait intro à prendre
mais rassure les autres que c'est une
une victoire de la crédibilité
pour emmanuel macron peut-être pas par
ko mais met au point
moi j'ai trouvé je l'aï dit au début
j'ai trouvé que il avait une maîtrise il
démontré une maîtrise qui était qui
offrait un contraste frappant avec sa
façon se raccrocher à ces fiches sur
cette énormité qu'elle à sortir les
sites et une sur sur les effets
soi-disant bénéfiques du break site qui
n'a pas encore eu lieu
bon donc j'ai vu de tout trouver du
poids du la crédibilité certes il avait
marqué des points
et puis aussi il a assumé ses options
libérale pro européenne
alors peut-être que ça ne lui rapportera
pas une voix à gauche et notamment dans
le public qui a voté jean luc mélenchon
parce que ça c'est sûr que tout lol
façon dont il a abordé les
problématiques économiques et répulsive
pour ce public là en revanche parmi les
gens qui ont voté pour fillon et qui ne
voulaient pas voter peut-être que ça
peut faire un peu bouger
avez vous une vraie question emmanuel
macron a dit et redit qu'il ne change
rien à son programme économique
notamment sur la loi travail qu'il a su
quand même cette partie oliviero quand
elle sera dure à avaler pour de nombreux
français qui l'ont mal vécu qu'ils ont
combattu dans la rue
oui bien dib et un second tour un débat
de second tour ça doit permettre aux
candidats d'élargir un peu ses soutiens
et les deux là sortent de là vraiment
sans avoir fait le travail parce que
emmanuel macron n'a pas du tout ne s'est
pas aventuré sur la question sociale
or c'est un des grands reproches qui lui
est fait il est audible sur l'économie
sur l'europe
même sur le régalien mais sur le social
il y à bien il a bien évoqué légèrement
l'assurance universel d'assurance
chômage universel mais et puis le
remboursement de en matière de santé
mais au delà il n'y a pas véritablement
encore structurée de propositions
sociales
quant à marine le pen elle est restée
elle aussi dans le son comment dire à
son niveau parce que elle est dans la
dénonciation
elle est dans une posture de
dénonciation ce qui fait que elle ne
sort pas de l'image globale qui est le
parti du front national fait des
constats négatifs et dénonce des
situations mais finalement en termes de
gouvernabilité bien c'est un point
d'interrogation et de vie qu en
politique comme en amour ya pas que mon
amour d'ailleurs j'ai l'a6 et l'a7
évidemment il ya que des preuves d'amour
est ce qu'il aurait fallu qu'ils donnent
plus la preuve d'amour politique
emmanuel macron will sans doute auront
il ya deux préceptes inde rendant dans
l'élection présidentielle choix vème
république c'est au premier tour en
rassemble son camp au deuxième on
élargit et puis on a un deuxième c'est
au premier tour les électeurs
choisissent et au second tour il élimine
eh bien on al impression qu emmanuel
macron il fait le pari qu'il remportera
cette élection sur le 2ème préceptes et
que finalement les électeurs élimineront
marine le pen alors elle de son point de
vue effectivement elle a sans doute pas
beaucoup élargi son socle parce qu'elle
a effectivement surtout été dans la
dénonciation faite sa stratégie du début
à la fin c'était d'essayer de faire des
manuels macron le candidat sortant là où
sa stratégie n'a pas forcément très bien
fonctionné c'est que finalement emmanuel
macron assume à la fois d'avoir été au
pouvoir et puis d'avoir démissionné de
l'avoir de l'avoir quittée donc d'avoir
rompu avec avec le chef de l'état
il ya quelque chose d'assez frappant
assez que ces derniers jours emmanuel
macron justement pour élargir un peu
son socle avait dit plusieurs fois qu'il
ne considèrerait pas son élection comme
un chèque en blanc
c'est une formule qu'il aurait pu
reprendre ce soir il ne l'a pas fait
peut-être parce qu'il considère que de
toute façon maintenant pour l'essentiel
l'élection et jouets qu'il sera
peut-être un président mal élu mais que
c'est que finalement une fois élu qu'il
devra essayer de rassembler largement en
vue des les chamois il m'a donné
l'impression d'avoir clairement de
stratégie chacune une pour un électorat
pour l'électorat de droite un discours
libéral assumé effectivement pas du tout
un discours social et pour l'électorat
de gauche la re diabolisation et son
mari ont fait de pierrot
c'est en tout cas ce qu'il essaie de
faire en tout cas c'est plus cohérent de
faire ça que de tenir un discours
économique il pourra séduire les
électeurs de meyrin chaud et les experts
de fillon s'est rendu très bon puis à
l'économie il ya les chiffres qui sont
têtus vous nous le rappelait souvent ici
ce soir mais il ya aussi et bien le
mouvement l'adhésion l'enthousiasmé
aussi est important les deux candidats
sont nouveaux entre guillemets c'est la
première fois qu'il débatte ainsi parce
qu'il est passé cet empire
ils ont l'air tous les deux ans tous
dias mais je vois pas tellement que 12e
ils vont pouvoir faire au au delà de
l'écran l'enthousiaste aurait pu faire
mâcon c'était justement cette affaire de
rassemblements etc
mais en fin de compte je pense que dans
sa tête il sait que ce rassemblement est
impossible donc il va pas perdre son
temps à essayer de convaincre des gens
qui ne l'aiment pas de l'aimer puisqu'on
parlait d'amour a juste à la scène
donc il ya ce premier point le problème
ensuite on voyait bien la différence
alors qu'est ce qui va être le plus
enthousiasmant fin le plus
enthousiasmant qu'est ce que dit madame
le pen par rapport aux problèmes de
l'extérieur inique la solution elle dit
que la solution c'est la frontière
qu'est ce que dit monsieur macron sur la
question de l'extérieur il dit la
solution c'est la flexibilité la
compétitivité donc c'est bien demande
complètement différence c'est bien ça je
vois la frontière c'est la protection
par la frontière et lui la protection
passera par la flexibilité la
compétitivité et donc est alors quand il
dit par exemple c'est intéressant quand
il dit d'autres ont réussi bon ils ont
réussi peut-être moins à mon sens à
moitié m'enfin ils ont moins raté que
nous et mieux réussi que nous le dire
les choses de cette façon
lorsqu'il parle du descente de la
décentralisation du droit du travail
mais justement ce qui est très
intéressant de voir c'est que
l'allemagne n'a pas fait du tout ce
qu'ils proposent sur la question des
licences de tout le travail tôt tout se
fait par la branche ce que propose
madame le pen mais pourquoi tout se fait
par la branche en allemagne et tout ne
peut pas se faire par la branche en
france à cause du mouvement syndical
c'est à dire qu'il ya un syndicat qui
est d'accord complètement les syndicats
sont complètement d'accord pour jouer le
jeu je sais bien qu aux dernières
élections la cfdt a remporté le gros
morceau mais ce n'est pas le cas de la
france donc la solution avec elle se
trouve mâcon c'est que cette flexibilité
recherchée
cette compétitivité rechercher il ne
peut la trouver que dans la
décentralisation totale
il habille les entreprises et qui pose
quand même et la madame le pen je crois
à raison posera un certain nombre de
problèmes mais on n'y a pas de solution
qui ne posent pas d'autres problèmes ça
n'existe pas juste pour dire qu' il y a
quand même chez emmanuel macron au delà
de la flexibilité l'aspect sécurité et
l'aspect intégration à la mondialisation
c'est à dire qu'il parle beaucoup d'une
france dans le concert des nations qui
négocient qui discutent et qui s'insère
dans ce qui est le monde aujourd'hui
c'est à dire un ensemble de réseaux où
il faut être présent pour défendre et
promouvoir des intérêts et ses skis avec
l'idée de frontière disparaît
complètement du discours de l'autre côté
de marine le pen donc le le clivage
s'est pas simplement frontières
flexibilité ses frontières et insertion
dans les canaux de fleigneux royaume de
la mondialisation l'autre et dont
l'essentiel vous en parlez vous avez
tout de prendre la parole patrick
capelle mer c'est l'europe c'est leur on
attendait vraiment une clarification
puisqu'on a dit que ce débat devait être
l'heure de la clarification sur la
proposition de marine le pen qu'elle a
tenté d'expliciter ce soir et emmanuel
macron qui a tenté de la combattent sur
ce sujet on écoute cet échange
moi je veux une europe qui va plus vite
une europe qui protège qui est moins
bureaucratiques ou mais on a besoin de
l'europe dans la mondialisation
vingt-cinq ans que vous promettez
l'europe sociale vous et vos amis
socialistes madame lebaye sackhoff et
pas 25 ans nous avons subi une
désindustrialisation massive
nous avons subi l'effondrement de nos
ampoules de nos emplois et les
délocalisations massives et aujourd'hui
parce que les accords n'ont pas été les
dignes des années ça l'euro cela les
programmes l'état français est en danger
à cause de leur cause de votre projet à
cause de l'europe aux gars
non mais c'est très important moi je ne
sais qui nous écoutent mof comprendre si
l'état stratège que je mènerai n'est pas
là pour taper du poing sur la table et
pour empêcher la loi sur l'union
bancaire qui en cas de défaillance
bancaire ira piocher directement dans
les comptes en banque des épargnants un
signe dans la laure assurance vie
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'ils ont fait à
chypre est très calme et leur ce moment
il est attendu il est attendu pour
savoir en termes de pouvoir d'achat en
termes skin impact sur notre
portefeuille quelles peuvent être les
conséquences de la proposition de marine
le pen est ce qu'elle est au clair on
voit bien que dans beaucoup d'aspects ne
tient pas mis sur l'abandon de l'euro ni
sur les conditions dans lesquelles des
négociations pourrait pourrait se
conduire et que finalement sa vision de
l'européenne de l'europe se limite
effectivement aux barbelés à la
frontière refus de l'immigration qui
présentait comme comme le mâle majeur
qui menace sur le plan économique sur le
plan identitaire sur le plan sécuritaire
etc
la population française de l'autre côté
je ne suis pas sûr que emmanuel macron
soit plus rassurant parce que lorsqu'il
se gausse de ceux qui trouvent que la
mondialisation c'est trop dur il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont sur les plans
de licenciements qui sont confrontés à
la déréglementation du travail à des
concurrences etc qui ont dû entendre
cette phrase de façon assez désagréable
et ensuite sur les protections propose
c'est au contraire sur le plan de
l'assurance chômage
de réduire les possibilités de durée du
chômage c'est d'étendre ce qui a été
dans la loi macron à l'origine du fait
que maintenant 50% moins de salariés se
présente devant les prud'hommes parce
que c'est de plus en plus difficile
ils vont encore aggraver sa avec des
pénalités précisent et aggraver ce qui
n'avait pas été obtenu dans la loi
quelle connerie
bref sur le plan de la protection il ne
présente rien il présente une pétition
d'optimisme qui est rentrons dans le
marché avec avec audace et on continuera
comme ça se passe aujourd'hui c'est à
dire qu'il y avait d'une que d'un côté
une robe résolu et qui portait une veine
très forte et de l'autre côté une roue
béatitude dans laquelle les français ne
peuvent pas prendre
alors ça c'est important le devais que
fo quel est votre avis est ce qu'il ya
une tête des vidéos c'est vrai qu
emmanuel macron certains ont reproché sa
vision entre guillemets naïve un de
l'europe en même temps qu'on voit la
sortie de marine le pen
escorté la la candidate du front
national qu air également donné ses
premières impressions je vous laisse
commenter quand même cette loi sur le
co2 de discours et de visions
diamétralement opposées alors la vision
des monnaies macro on la connaissait et
il l'a assumé ce soir effectivement même
si ça peut inquiéter un certain nombre
d'électeurs de français qui ont plutôt
l'impression de subir finalement à la
fois la mondialisation et le
fonctionnement l'union européenne tel
qu'il existe aujourd'hui
néanmoins ce qu'on attendait c'était
surtout une clarification de marine le
plein sur ce sujet là puisque depuis
quelques jours c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que c'est la confusion
sur ce sur ce sujet là puisque c'est
plus très bien
à quelles conditions et sous quel délai
elle elle voudrait soumettre à
référendum la sortie de l'union
européenne et de l'euro on sait qu'il ya
cet accord avec nicolas dupont aignan
par lequel finalement elle n'a pas non à
un moment à la cité des gaullistes et
elle a néanmoins dans cet accord on
explique cet accord explique que la
sortie de l'euro et de l'union
européenne n'est plus un préalable à
toute politique économique alors on
comprend bien pourquoi elle a fait ça
parce que l'un de ses réservoirs de voix
potentielles ce sont les électeurs un
peu âgé de de françois fillon qu'elle
pourrait récupérer mais qui eux sont
affirmés tous les électorats agit et qui
sont très inquiets à lire sa quête de
valeurs d'une éventuelle à une partie
complètement filandreuse où elle
expliqué en gros que tous nos
partenaires européens à aller plus ou
moins rapidement adopté la même démarche
vous dites ce soir que les deux visions
selon vous enfin si on peut dire ne sont
pas totalement satisfaite parce que si
elle n'est pas au clair sur sa
proposition de sortie de l'euro lui il
reste encore peut-être trop optimiste
pour ceux qui se sentent dépossédés ou
des laissés sur le bas côté sans
toutefois cette vision là on la
connaissait et c'est son pari en
revanche on sait plus trop bien où en
est marine le pen aurait elle même
reconnaît que 70% de son programme
économique ne peut pas être appliquée si
la france ne sort pas de l'union
européenne ce qui pose tout de même un
problème là on est en plein dans la
phrase de martine aubry en 2011 quand
c'est flou c'est qu'il ya un loup qui
nous semble assez assez gros oui mais
c'est le problème économique mais c'est
aussi le problème juridique et
institutionnel parce que pour sortir de
l'union européenne il faut ou pour
sortir la zone euro il faut quand même
suivre des procédures
tout ceci n'est pas précisé il faut
faire une révision de la constitution
puisque nous avons un titre 16 qui est
consacrée à l'union européenne le
programme du front national dit qu'il
veut marine le pen dit qu'il veut
supprimer
ce titre il faut faire une révision
constitutionnelle et là ça nous renvoie
et c'est là aussi floue mais c'est
fréquent aussi dans
le commentaire que nous faisons ça nous
renvoie aux législatives et c indiquent
à quel point la suite et je motive notre
stratégie qu'un bon on a déjà dans la
bataille d'après alors sans surprise
judith waintraub les différents sondages
qui sont réalisées ce soir donne plus
convaincant emmanuel macron largement à
plus de 60% mais écartons les sondages à
un moment puisque vous êtes journaliste
vous avez vos différents quotidiens si
vous deviez choisir un titre pour votre
quotidien
demain at il assez court et ça résume je
trouve très bien une soirée
qu'est-ce que vous choisiriez bas la une
du figaro pendant découvriront la vraie
une tout à l'heure oui j'ai plein gré
pour résumer je dirai pas plus clair pas
plus claire maintenant à l'issue se
développe on y est entré
malheureusement pas très capable müller
à la une de l'humanité qu'est ce que
vous mettriez ou peut-être l'avenir est
ailleurs
oui alors à midi je dirais moi président
olivier rault quant à moi j'ai pas de
journal je ne sais pas match nul
ah ouais mais pas de sens dit il
un bon titre i'm voulait alors là vous
parlez malheureusement du niveau du
débat peut-être sévère mais ce qui alors
beaucoup de ce soir ludovic faut même
question encore trois jours pour aller
passer ensemble soit poursuivre notre
édition spéciale
merci à vous legrand décryptage sur
public sénat et lcp n ludovic faut
toujours à mes côtés
après ce débat ce soir entre deux tours
quels effets sur l'électorat les
électorats mène cette france qu'on
décrit comme divisée on va en parler
juste après avoir écouté les propos les
premiers propos l'introduction des deux
camps les dalles a quand même donné le
ton cette introduction par sa virulence
et même son agressivité en écoute écoute
et je suis extrêmement heureuse de la
manière dont se déroule ce second tour
parce que la réalité c'est que le choix
politique les français
vont devoir faire c'est clair je suis la
candidate du peuple je suis la candidate
de la france tel que nous l'aimons de sa
culture de sa civilisation de son unité
je suis la candidate de la nation qui
protège qui protège nos emplois qui
protège la sécurité de nos compatriotes
qui protège nos frontières qui nous
protège face à la concurrence
internationale déloyale et face à la
montée en puissance du fondamentalisme
islamiste
face à cet esprit de défaite moi je
porte l'esprit de conquête français
parce que la france a toujours réussi
et elle a toujours réussi dans le monde
parce qu'elle est au monde sa longue
elle se parle sur tous les continents
son histoire sa civilisation ce qui fait
sa force c'est précisément qu'elle
rayonne partout ce qui fait que nous
sommes aujourd'hui la cinquième
puissance économique mondiale
c'est que nous sommes forts dans le
monde il y avait énormément de
changements à faire énormément ce sont
ceux là que je veux conduire et c'est
l'incapacité des gouvernements depuis
tenté tant d'années pour le 80 ans je
n'ai jamais été ni premier ministre ni
président de la république madame le pen
je vais faire le maximum pour remédier à
cela
mais ces changements profonds que je
souhaite qu'ils m'ont conduit quand
j'étais ministre à quitter le
gouvernement
c'est bien cela que je compte mener à
leur terme pour que cet esprit conquête
triomphe
c'est ça la france que je veux c'est ça
la france qui nous ressemble pas la
vôtre et merci d'être avec nous sur les
chaînes politique et parlementaire
public sénat et lcp n après le débat
d'entre deux tours et à trois jours du
scrutin à l'analyse et le décryptage
avec toujours à mes côtés ludovic faux
journalistes politiques lcp n est autour
de nous notre chroniqueur jean les
gombos qui est resté également le
politologue olivier rouquan et on
accueille avec plaisir et le dit ville
s'arrête bonsoir vous êtes sémiologue
spécialiste en communication verbale et
non verbale ça va nous être très utile
ce soir nicolas boudot bonsoir soit en
communiquant associé du cabinet de
communication
tine des rejets tout de suite vous
donner la parole et l'osier on va
commencer avec vous on a beaucoup parlé
du fonds un peu de la forme vous comment
vous avez perçu ce duel on avait entendu
avant ce débat que ça pouvait être un
combat de catch de boxe lui même lutte
gréco romaine on a passé en revue tous
les sports qu'est ce que vous avez vu ce
soir moi ce qui m'a beaucoup interpellé
c'est les sourires un qui a été très
nombreuses
pendant une heure il ya eu des sourires
qui était effectivement un peu trop
carnassier pour être tout à fait tout à
fait sincère et qui en fait caché bien
la violence fin caché bien été un indice
de la violence symbolique qui était qui
étaient en cours ce qui était un un
petit peu attristant quand même c'est le
fait que justement pendant une heure on
a vraiment été sur des questions de
forme
on a été sur du métal discours c'est à
dire que chacun s'est amusé à commenter
soissons propres propos soit le propos
de l'autre et c'est vrai que balla on
est retombé dans la politique
politicienne qui est celle que les
français détestent déteste le plus
kindel a pas l'exacte on était que sur
des questions de posture et même des
rapports de force tout à fait archaïque
et donc voila c'était ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui a servi le débat et je
vous entends des tout à l'heure par les
deux matches nuls je pense
qu'effectivement on était dans ce type
de registre qu'elle sert hérités d'un
boom était zéro pointé au lala nicolas
boudot forcément on a en tête les débats
récents de 2012 de 2007 et même
puisqu'on a vu ces derniers jours tous
les extraits des débats vraiment
historique si on devait les comparer est
ce que celui ci ressemble un peu plus à
cette époque twitter réseaux sociaux ça
va vite où il faut attaquer répondre
argumenté oui c'est un débat en 140
caractères avec 2 avec deux caractères
mais 140 caractères des phrases
extrêmement court 2 égaux face à face
qui se parlaient en miroir bon assez peu
à mon avis deux prises avec avec
l'opinion publique et on sentait qu'il y
avait dans ce débat un débat dans le
débat avec un emmanuel macron qui avait
besoin de gérer son avance ce qui la
fait techniquement sur les sujets
économiques
il n'ya pas discussion là dessus un seul
instant une seule minute et même sur
l'intégralité du débat et marine le pen
qui elle probablement anticipant un
score moins élevées que ce qu'elles
pouvaient espérer jouer la carte de la
de la future cheffe de l'opposition et
en seul enseignement s'asseoir à
l'avenue incarner une forme de colère
des français souvent maladroitement il
faut le dire mais malgré tout elle a
voulu incarner une forme de colère des
francs
cette colère qui s'est exprimée au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle à hauteur de 45 % donc de
ce point de vue là c'est une réussite
pour chacun puisque il avait l' objectif
emmanuel macron ne pas perdre trop de
points et marine le pen être considéré
dimanche soir sur le coup de 20 heures
comme la chef de l'opposition
en attendant les législatives pour le
reste deux batailles d'ego beaucoup de
boxe pour à mon avis il n'y a pas
beaucoup de fond du fond on en avait eu
en 2012 on a vu en 2007 et dans tous les
débats dans tous les débats précédents y
compris 95 autres par leur épure là il
ya une vraie rupture mais vous l'avez
dit vous-même dans votre question nous
avons assisté à un débat qui est dans
l'air du temps avec des anathèmes
extrêmement courts et extrêmement
violent c'est intéressant ce que vous
dites elle est déjà dans la bataille
d'après des législatives et on a déjà
l'impression va écouter un extrait vous
à nous dire ce qu'ils en pensent et
ludovic faut qu'elle veut déjà
fragilisés l'éventuelle le probable le
possible futur président de la
république puisqu'elle parle de lui
comme d'un candidat par défaut mais du
jour au lendemain on serait présidente
les gens vont arrêter de venir il n'y
aura plus de fraude sociale plus de
fraude fiscale tout va bien se passer du
jour au lendemain comme ça formidable
mais c'est formidable et celles non moi
j'ai pas envie de me montrer j'ai pas
envie je suis mieux de faire j'ai pas
envie d'essayer
alors que les français n'ont plus envie
d'essayer avec v les français ne parlait
pas alors planant sur n'a pas à leur
place mais ils ont envie tous savaient
plus où la position aujourd'hui du
candidat parmi les fausses a choisi
fardée par toute une série de gens alors
vous devriez faire preuve d'un peu moins
d'arrogance je m'appelle élections vous
dit est ce que c'est une attaque qui
peut faire mouche candidat par défaut
pour un peut-être peut-être attendre et
voir 7 mai un futur président qui
partirait avec un peu les mains peut
lier situation que ça correspond à une
réalité un puisque d'après un sondage
qui a été publiée aujourd'hui par par le
monde
60% des électeurs des modèles macron
disque effectivement leur vote pour ce
candidat est plutôt un vote par défaut
de raisons plutôt que de conviction et
d'ailleurs le rapport de force s'est
inversé et concernant marine le pen
puisque elle s'est plutôt à 59% 60% d'un
vote un vote d'adhésion seulement selon
ses électeurs donc ça correspond à une
réalité et effectivement c'est toute la
difficulté de l'équation poste
présidentiel on voit effectivement que
marine le pen tente déjà de commencer à
jouer le 3e tour en quelque sorte que
feront les élections législatives et
emmanuel macron
lors de ces élections législatives sera
sera confronté effectivement à une vraie
difficulté qui sera celle d'obtenir une
majorité pour pouvoir mener sa politique
et de ce point de vue là on est dans la
stratégie de marine le pen un qui sauf
accident électoral effectivement c'est
sans doute qu'elle ne qu'elle ne
remportera pas cette élection parce que
quand on fait le compte aujourd'hui des
scores de premier tour des reports
potentiel il faudrait pour que marine le
pen lan porte aujourd'hui qu'elles
réussissent à attirer à elle l'ensemble
des indécis qui sont aujourd'hui cinq à
six millions ça semble ça semble une
équation quand même assez compliqué et
donc elle fait le pari déjà aujourd'hui
d'une entrée en force de députés front
national à l'assemblée en juin prochain
pour déjà préparer l'élection de 2022
puisque en 2022 le front national roi
des élus locaux depuis les
départementales et régionales aura
peut-être plusieurs dizaines de députés
et à ce moment là dans cinq ans marine
le pen pourra prétendre dans une
position peut être plus plus plus
crédible être une candidate à la
victoire finale pour l'élection
présidentielle
on va mêler le fond et la forme et le 10
mai la règle qu'on peut dire 2h30
invectives ce soir un débat et un duel
vraiment sans merci de france qui se
font vraiment face et on l'a vu elle a
tenté par une le pen à plusieurs
reprises de faire sortir emmanuel macron
de ses gonds c'est vraiment sa stratégie
bulldozer elle était clair comme de
l'eau de roche
qu'est ce que vous en avez pensé lui en
tous les cas n'a pas mordu la ligne il
n'est pas sorti tout à fait alors il y
avait quand même une progression qui
était assez notable c'est à dire dans
une première partie effectivement marine
le pen très agressive très offensive
beaucoup d' attaques ad hominem d'attac
à la personne que emmanuel macron
essayer dé construire en permanence
puisque à chaque foyer recadrer le
discours en disant mais ne parlez pas de
parler de votre projet à vous
et donc voilà une première partie de
même il a il a été quand même pas et n'a
pas été aussi bon que cela puisque même
il a fait parfois des erreurs
stratégiques
quand il disait j'assume tout le monde
accepte et on sent que il ya un point de
bascule c'est à dire qu'à partir de 22h
l'a finalement il est plus calme et il
prend davantage le temps de pouvoir
argumenter et sur la question du
terrorisme effectivement là il a pu
dérouler tout son argumentaire est alors
ce qui était intéressant aussi c'est que
certainement fatigué de recadrer en
permanence marine le pen il s'est laissé
aller un peu plus dans son territoire
elle et lui même a fait des attaques ad
hominem ce qu'on lui connaissait assez
peu parce que voilà c'est une stratégie
il le dit lui-même d'ailleurs ne
sifflait pas mais allez plutôt
convaincre donc lui est vraiment dans
cette posture là mais finalement il n'a
réussi à bien à bien se débrouiller en
étant dans ce territoire là d' attaque
aussi personnelle quand il dénonce par
exemple les sièges européens qui sont
vides et c'est finalement il a su user
de ça mais ce qui était aussi marquant
c'est tous les éléments de langage qui
tournaient en boucle et qui faisait que
quand même le débat était été assez
creux donc c'est l arrogance leur mari
de crem je suis pas d'accord avec sa
foule ça fait non je suis pas d'accord
avec ça parce que tout est parce qu on a
40 a déjà à tous les peuples attendent
un débat on veut qu une des
personnalités se dégage
on ne veut pas simplement avoir des
propositions on veut voir notre futur
président de la république
est-ce que deux oui madame le pen on la
connaît très bien monsieur makoun ne le
connais pas trop le connais si bien
alors qu'elle a quand même beaucoup
tenté de changer son image on attendait
aussi son caractère son caractère
parfois impulsif agressif que nous le
connaissons quand même depuis quelques
années monsieur macro on ne sait pas
trop si les gentils méchants
si les conciliants combatif on ne sait
pas trop où carré des arts et s'asseoir
et ben je crois que ce soit il montre
qu'il a une certaine stature quand même
et qu' il se laisse pas marcher sur les
pieds
il répond de manière quand on la grèce
il répond il que je m'habille là nul
n'est pas amis oui la mi temps mais ça
me rappelle le débat entre eux madame
royal et monsieur sarkozy à l'endroit ya
là beaucoup agressé monsieur sarkozy
rappelez-vous en pensant le déstabiliser
et n'y est pas parvenu on a découvert un
sarkozy beaucoup plus qu'un
on ne le croyez et elle même l'a
découvert ce qui fait d'ailleurs que
dans le genre de débat on n'a pas
intérêt à jouer sur une psychologie
supposée de l'adversaire on n'a pas du
tout intérêt à faire ça et c'est ce que
fait madame le pen et d'ailleurs je vous
jure je suis d'accord avec vous en fait
ce qu'elle veut c'est être présidente de
l'opposition pas être présidente de la
république
donc elle n'a pas besoin de faire des
propositions
elle a besoin de faire de la
contestation donc c'est ce qu'elle a
fait donc de cette façon là ou quoi de
vue stratégique
je crois qu'elle a parfaitement rempli
son affaire et l'autre en face à
parfaitement également rempli son
affaire oui va même si on a quand même
eu à certains moments de la part d'
emmanuel macron des sorties qui de pour
moi était à la limite de du débat et on
a même franchi les points godwin
plusieurs fois lui faisait des guides
des clins d'oeil plus qu'appuyé et des
références au nazisme puisque c'est ça
un point godwin
c'est le réduction à dix clés room de
manière assez systématique aussi bien
sur vichy que sur la schlague et c'est
que j'ai pas trouvé moi complètement
complètement digne et au niveau du débat
c'est la vie c'est bon ça c'est pas
efficace mais en plus il s'est abaissé
au niveau de la stratégie de marine le
pen qui dès la première seconde du débat
avait décidé de lui sauter à de lui
sauter à la gorge et de le renvoyer
dit elle à son statut d'ancien ministre
et deux successeurs putatifs en tout cas
dans la bouche de marine le pen de de
françois hollande est lui en essayant de
placer marine le pen dans un créneau
d'ultra ultra droite il a à mon avis
contribué à l'abaissement à
l'abaissement du débat et en cela c'est
plutôt à mon avis une erreur une erreur
en termes de communication politique
plus qu'un plus qu'une vidéo il n'aurait
pas dû forcément aller la chercher ce
dont cet accord sur le terrain des
valeurs alors là elle est effectivement
ce qu'on n'est pas totalement d accord
mais la question en fait que je
soulevais été celle de la vacuité à
certains moments du débat et qui tient
du fait notamment que certaines
structures linguistiques étaient
similaires
revenez en permanence et et ne dit pas
de bêtise moi j'ai un projet sérieux
vous êtes là à ruban et ça effectivement
ça ouais là par le bas ce qui est quand
même ce qui risque de frustrer un
certain nombre de téléspectateurs c'est
finalement alors le connaître mieux je
n'en suis pas sûr parce que c'est
tellement h et qu' on n'a pas au centre
mais je vais arrêter la france danser
dans ce débat on parle de petites
propositions ici ou là quand on peut en
parler de dénonciation de la posture de
l'autre mais quel est le lien
qu'entretient le candidat et quelle est
sa vision de la france
on sait très bien qu'un débat c'est pas
un discours mais on pouvait se rappeler
notamment des débats du premier tour et
se rappeler jean luc mélenchon une
qualité une cuve est à dire une surface
lorsqu'il est à fait saisissante donc le
rapport mitterrand aurait dit charnelle
ou de gaulle littéraire peu importe à la
france là on ne l'a pas et c'est là
aussi on à la moulinette de cette
communication vous avez instantanée un
kid qui broie finalement incertain une
mémoire collective parce que c'est de
cela qu'il s'agit
et d'ailleurs on a également assez peu
parlé alors qu exane a beaucoup parlé
pendant tout le premier tour de
l'identité finalement de la nation on en
a ce soir assez peu parlé donc c'est
assez
c'est un point essentiel ludovic faux et
question peut-être une question que les
français se pose c'est quelle france
incarnent les candidats qui l'on veut
par exemple parce que les faut pas
oublier que ce soir pour la première
fois donc les deux souligné parce que
depuis on s'est habitué c'est ce qu'on
appelle la normalisation peut-être du
front national mais c'était quand même
c'est la candidate du front national qui
a débattu c'est une première donc il
faut la paix par rapport à 2010 j
jacques chirac représenter peut-être une
france un peu parfois rural du contact
qui il y avait une proximité
peut-être parfois faute mais il y avait
une proximité emmanuel macron quelle
france en présente il
les marine le pen r d'abord il ya 15 ans
effectivement un jacques chirac avait
refusé de débattre avec jean et l'open
là on a bien compris que maintenant avec
les scores que le front national réalise
le passage de relais entre jean marie le
pen et marine le pen on est rentré dans
dans une autre ère et finalement les
débats de premier tour l'ont voulons
bien montrer un plus personne n'imagine
maintenant tenir le front national à
l'écart de ces débats là et d'ailleurs
ça ne servirait sans doute pas grand
chose parce que finalement on a bien vu
en 2002 que l'ostracisme ostracisé de
façon réelle ou supposée le front
national finalement n'était n'était pas
très efficace puisque jean marie le pen
s'était retrouvé au second tour et si
les six ici les opposants au front
national veut le combattre il faut le
faire sur le terrain des valeurs et des
propositions bon sur la france qui
incarne emma l'incarnation c'est
important c'est une france alors que lui
veut ouverte combative conquérante 1
c'est ça recoupe d'ailleurs ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure sur sur sa
conception de la société de l'europe et
de la mondialisation c'est c'est une
france qui se veut optimiste
la question est de savoir si si cette
vision peut parler à 50% des français +1
pour être élu alors ça oui
vraisemblablement il aura ce il aura ce
résultat la séparent de leur parler
parce que mais on est pour l'instant
effectivement dans cette idée qu'on est
plutôt dans une élection par par défaut
et que finalement tout restera si
emmanuel macron l'emportent
effectivement tout restera à faire et à
bâtir au lendemain de l'élection
présidentielle et de ce point de vue là
emmanuel macron va être confronté à
plusieurs défis
la nomination d'un premier ministre il
faudra qu'ils envoient un signe à ce
moment là alors qu'elle signe va-t-il
envoyé à quai laquelle france à la
droite à la gauche au centre et c'est ça
qui lui permettra ensuite
de bâtir ou pas une majorité donc on
voit bien la france que qu'emmanuel
macron veut construire quelle est sa
vision de la france
on voit pas encore forcément avec avec
qui il va il va ils valent à bâtir et
comment il va y arriver
on dirait ça pour les deux d'ailleurs
pour les deux mais je pense que non il
faut bien voir que madame le pen c'est
la france éternelle c'est la france des
cathédrales et de la fête de la
fédération et du conseil national de la
résistance
en gros c'est ça la france de monsieur
macron c'est la france dans l'europe
sait et c'est fondamental c'est à dire
qu' il ne peut pas penser la france sans
penser une france forte en europe une
france diluée dans l'europe c'est ça
qu'on veut savoir alors voilà c'est
alors c'est ça la question qui
évidemment on lui arrache tout est maman
alors lui il dit que c'est la france
forte dans l'europe et c'est comme ça
qu'elle ne sera pas diluée dans l'europe
mais il ne peut pas pense et c'est à
dire que pour lui
votre vision de la france une poser la
question comme ça ça n'a pas de sens ça
n'a pas de sens
on ne peut pas la pensée sans l'europe
ce n'est plus possible c'est donc en
fait c'est comme ça qu'ils voient non
mais je sais bien que il ya plein de
français qui décroche quand on dit ça
allait oui bien sûr c'est un là il ya un
problème politique absolument majeur est
d'ailleurs sur la question monétaire par
exemple en fait pour répondre aux
questions que vous posez que vous posez
ludovic justement il est il est pas
clair il n'est pas clair et justement sa
force c'est s'appuyer sur la faiblesse
total de marine le pen sur cette
question il est fort de la fréquence de
marie le plagiste ont préparé la vous
montrer ma prochaine question il est
fort de sa faiblesse et donc n'a t-il
pas installé même si elle est arrivée
au second tour parce qu'elle a été
portée par des millions de français
nicolas baudry olic et le dim exactes
mais n'en at il pas fait sa première
opposante d'office également de fête
pour la suite
alors je vais pas répondre directement
votre question en fait puisqu'on était
sur les questions de forme et de
scénographie moi ce qui m'a beaucoup
interrogé c'est ce que du coup ce qui
est toujours intéressant c'est de
regarder aussi sur les réseaux sociaux
ce qui se passe pendant le le débat
effectivement cette alerte enlèvement
qui arrêtent qui a été prononcée à un
moment donné sur les journalistes
on s'est demandé cervélo est ce qu'ils
étaient au départ l'idée dé pour faire
quoi qu'ils étaient tous les cas du coup
alors exercice très difficile qui va je
cesserai de juger tout à fait mais qui
du coup pose la question aussi de la
scénographie de la mise en scène et quel
est le rôle journalistique qu'on propose
demain dans ce type d'intervention est
dans ce type de débat puisque on voit
que dit qu'on aurait pu les laisser
débattre tout seul
oui la posture est classique dans un
duel de ce type
mélangeant là ils ont reperdu le cours
d'eau parfois ce qui était peut-être par
mais avec des candidats qui avaient un
autre style c'est à dire c'est la
culture qui changent et on voit qu'à le
rôle en effet mais dans les duels de
débat de second tour les journalistes
sont là pour arbitrer autre temps mais
nous on est 15 h à dire attaché aux
débats traditionnels de la vème
république c'est vrai qu'on a un peu
perdu ce soir sous la même forme qu'en
fait c'était le décrochage est
effectivement cette notion de du public
qui décroche et oui parce qu'à un moment
donné on passer du coq à l'âne c'était
tout à fait décousu on savait pas
quelles étaient les thématiques abordées
et donc voilà quel est le rôle
journalistique à ce moment là est-ce que
jusqu'où va le recadrage enfin c'est une
vraie question qui se pose et qui
ressort à la lumière de ce débat
ça va très bien aussi une question why
est aussi une question de communication
politique parce que ici on imagine ce
qu'aurait été un débat parfait pour nous
ici autour de la table je suis là qui n
mais qui sommes éduqués et qui avions
probablement je parle en notre nom à
tous envie d'un débat de fond projet
contre projet avec des critiques un peu
technique ce n'est pas nécessairement ce
que voulait l'opinion publique qui est
parfois friands de
combat tel que celui que nous avons six
mois je crois qu'elle est vraiment en
attente
ben je sais pas j'ai pas là débat de
fond bien plus que nous par cholet
journal affirmant à la réponse à la
question le croit mais en tout cas on
s'attendait à ça et peut-être que et on
verra l'opinion publique s'attendait à
une bataille telle maison qu'il avait
cru que je voulais c'est la parole on va
coûter un dernier extrait de sa donne
change quand même qui est très
révélateur très vif sur la justice et
les juges n'en revenaient encore de
montrer à quel point vous êtes indigne
en insinuant que nos juges ne sont pas
indépendants je le regrette madame le
pen
la france mérite mieux que vous nos
juges à nos justes sur indépendant
globalement les jugements sont stables
indépendant les juges du syndicat de la
magistrature le pen monsieur ceux qui
ont épinglé des responsables politiques
et des parents de victimes sur un mur
des cons cela monsieur non ils sont
politisées n'aurait pas à votre avis
elle fait oui nos institutions et c'est
ça va aller soumettez-vous mairie vous
mettez le tout je me soumets à personne
vous êtes à plat ventre en permanence
devant l'allemagne devant le syndicat
devant lui au fief devant les
communautarismes suis devant les
puissances d'argent entre différents
voir les banques à plat ventre et madame
le candidat wrap l'avant je suis debout
mais pour être debout
je n'ai pas besoin de salir voilà il ya
eu cet échange et bien d'autres qui vous
donne une idée vraiment de la tonalité
de ce débat une question sous forme de
bilan les deux villes font on arrive à
la fin de notre édition spéciale on est
à trois jours du scrutin ce moment on
l'a dit souvent de débat d'entre deux
tours était très attendue selon vous
quels sont les points forts et les
points faibles de ce débat de ce duel ce
soir les points forts fils manuel macron
a sans doute marqué des points en termes
de présidentialité 1 parce qu'il a il a
montré effectivement qu'il était capable
au-delà des attaques et des invectives
de faire la pédagogie de son projet de
de l'expliquer de ne pas tomber malgré
tout dans l'outrance alors que marine le
pen a multiplié a malgré tout les contre
vérités les approximations sur un
certain nombre de dossiers techniques
elle a sans doute gagné c'est ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure ses galons
d'opposante numéro un même si ce sont
les élections législatives qui
décideront de tout ça la vérité c'est
que ce débat fera sans doute pas
beaucoup bouger les lignes d'ailleurs
jamais un débat d'entre deux tours
finalement n'a modifié et n'a bouleversé
la donne au point d'inverser finalement
les résultats des sondages faits avant
le débat et puis le le résultat le
résultat final donc vraisemblablement on
est dans cette configuration là
peut-être que
d'ici à d'ici à vendredi les sondages
d'intentions de vote bougeront d'un ou
deux points et on verra quel sera le
résultat
hainaut les hommes entrant en
vraisemblablement ce débat-là ne
changera pas la donne de cette élection
merci à vous merci on arrive à la fin de
cette édition spéciale merci surtout à
vous nous avoir accompagnés
merci le début qu'il faut pour ce
partenariat toujours aussi je l'espère
agréable pour vous avec lcp aide et
public sénat si vous souhaitez retrouver
ce décryptage et bien c'est à suivre
merci toujours de votre fidélité et à
demain avec plaisir
[Musique]